hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar generating protein reagents to
evaluate the antibody and cd8 positive t
cell responses to sars kobe 2.
i am jennifer woods of labrus and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar as a
part of the cell culture heroes series
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by gibco by thermo fisher scientific
to learn more about the cell culture
heroes webinar series or stay connected
on the latest event sponsored by gibco
please visit the resources tab
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
natalia guadalupe herrera
from the albert einstein college of
medicine
natalia you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone and thank you for joining
my webinar today
as was mentioned my name is natalia
guadalupe herrera and i'm currently a
graduate student in the lab of dr steven
elmo at albert einstein college of
medicine
and today i have the privilege to be
talking to you about a project which
really flourished during the pandemic
and it's titled generating protein
reagents to evaluate the antibody and
cd8 positive t cell responses to sars
cocktail
and so a little bit about me before we
begin
on the left is a picture of me and on
the right there's some contact
information in case anyone has any
further inquiries
my parents were born in mexico michoacan
i was born in the united states but
growing up i really didn't know a lot
about research um at all
it's actually one of the things that i
really liked learning so
even though my parents didn't get a
higher education i worked really hard
and got into college
and i ended up going to uc santa cruz
and became an official banana slug and
yes
the mascot is a yellow banana slug and
along the way i actually came across the
stem diversity programs at uc santa cruz
and these programs actually helped me
get a foot into research and actually
learn what research was
and actually do the research which is
really interesting so mark imsd and the
uc santa cruz genomics institute really
helped me
along the way
i was also part of the heritage medical
institute
for exceptional research opportunities
and the capstone programs
which actually added another
layer and helped me do more research in
another institution so if there's any
undergraduates here today or high school
students
and they're interested in research i
would encourage looking into programs
that can help you get access to research
and of course contacting
the principal investigators themselves
so i did a lot of my undergraduate
research at uc santa cruz
with dr victoria arbox stone
she studies the bacterial type 3
secretion system
which is here on the right
and it's a bacterial appendage that
almost looks like a needle
and the way it works is pretty
fascinating
it's able to inject
uh effective proteins into host cells
and actually
manipulate host defenses in that way
and the interesting thing is that
there's over two dozen gram-negative
pathogens that actually utilize this
type 3 secretion system to cause disease
one of which
is probably
well known which is the causative agent
of the black plague
in this lab we utilize your senior
tuberculosis as a model for studying the
function of the type 3 secretion system
and this is the less pathogenic version
of the plague
and i worked on screening the type 3
secretion system for bacterial virulence
factors and characterizing a lot of the
hits along the way
so along the way i did get to meet a lot
of very interesting people
who helped me
learn
science a lot of graduate students that
helped me learn science and techniques
and how to think about science
and i'm very appreciative of them here
so here's some pictures of our
shenanigans
so i also was a part of the heart he's
medical institute x-rap program
where i got paired up with dr dan
littman at the nyu school of medicine
and along with my other mentor dr jason
hall
uh they really taught me how to
think about science in a different
aspect so i was focused on microbiology
and they taught me a lot of immunology
uh and that's sort of what stuck with me
is immunology was very interesting and
something i wanted to pursue
in my graduate career
and so now i'm at graduate school in the
ammo lab
at albert einstein and i'm actually
having the privilege of also getting to
interact with and work with
the macromolecular therapeutic
development facility
now this facility shares the same
lab space as the elma lab so the
macromolecular therapeutic development
facility or mtdf
has a lot of nice resources that we can
use and i'll go through those resources
in a second
my pi steven ammo is the scientific
director
and one of the things we have access to
as well not just the physical resources
but a lot of the scientific
intellect is there as well so dr scott
garfurth
the operations director of the mcdf has
helped progress a lot of the projects in
our lab as well
so the mtdf is pretty interesting
because they have a lot of different
services they do high-throughput cloning
expression profiling so looking at
bacterial mammalian uh proteins
large scale or high throughput
production of proteins
uh and so it's of no surprise that the
alma lab is also
having similar interests in designing
and generating immunotherapy
and immunotherapies that are protein
based
as well as high throughput x-ray
crystallography and hydrogen screens for
finding novel binding partners in the
human secret home
so i'll go through a little bit about
the resources that the mtdf has to
really look at protein production in a
large scale
and so here is a picture of a robotics
platform
that allows us to liquid handle in a
high throughput fashion
here in the middle is a picture of a
96-well block where we're looking at
you know how we can grow up
bacteria in a 96-hole format
and then here on the right we have a
2-liter bottle that's really looking at
growth in a larger scale
for protein production
we also have the capacity to purify
proteins and so here's a picture of one
of the many fplc's that we utilize in
the lab
and just to show uh really the grandness
of it all like here's some gels they're
sds page shells or protein gels and
we're seeing the proteins uh
on several different sds page gels and
these are just an idea of how many
proteins we can purify in such a small
amount of time
so using this prokaryotic platform we've
been able to purify thousands of
proteins
and solve hundreds of structures
now moving on to the eukaryotic
platforms
so not every protein should be expressed
in a prokaryotic platform
this is obvious because some proteins
require post-translational modifications
which are only present in the eukaryotic
expression platforms and not in
prokaryotic platforms
so again we have robotics which allow us
to
set up for example hundreds of
transfections in a few hours or hundreds
of infections in eukaryotic cells
here is an ics page gel where we look at
small-scale baculovirus expression of
cytoplasmic adhesion proteins
and we can see that we can also do small
scale expression
of secreted proteins in sf9 or hi-fi
cells
and on the right we're looking at
small-scale expression in expo cho cells
looking at an icos ligand-based
immunotherapeutic
and so we really have different types of
expression platforms
we can use to look at different types of
proteins
and of course anything we can do in
small scale we can also do in a larger
scale
so you see here another series of sds
page shells looking at
the purification of several members of
the immunoglobulin super family
of course we also can do
large scale expressions and heteron3s
with
several proteins that are actually
some of them are immunotherapy some of
them are
immunoglobulin family members that are
fc fusion proteins
effectively taking the fc and dimerizing
proteins together
and finally on the right here i just
wanted to show an example
of why we really like to use different
expression platforms
so
we have a gel where we're looking at the
same immunotherapeutics except on the
left we have expression of those
immunotherapeutics in the xp293
platform and on the right we're looking
at the same immunotherapeutics expressed
and purified from an exp cho expression
platform
what we can see is that on the right
we're really sacrificing purity of those
immunotherapeutics because we're getting
cleavage products whereas on the left
those same immunotherapeutics do not get
cleaved in the xp293 platform
so really this is one of the things that
we can
take a step back and see the same
proteins
uh being expressed in two different
platforms
uh and trying to figure that out is one
of the things that we like to do
so when the pandemic hit the expertise
of the mtdf and
the alma lab was really required because
the scientific community needed to
produce large amounts of spike protein
from the stars cos2 virus so i'll
quickly just do a brief overview
of the virus and why the spike protein
is so important
so at the top we have as far as cough
two virus
and we notice that there are
some trimers spike primers protruding
from the source clef 2 viral membrane
the spike protein assembles naturally
into a trimeric state which is zoomed in
at the bottom
and the spike monomers themselves can
have two different conformations
so either the closed or the open
conformation and on the left we're
zooming into the closed conformation
what that means is that all the receptor
binding domains
are pointing down
so in the center we have the receptor
binding domains of each of the monomers
of spike
and they're all being closed off meaning
the receptor binding domain is not
accessible for binding to its receptor
which is ace2 or angiotensin converting
enzyme 2.
on the right
we have sort of a conformational shift
where one of the spike monomers in this
case is the cyan colored one
the receptor binding domain of that
monomer is pointing upwards and now is
accessible for binding to the
angiotensin converting enzyme to
receptor
and this interaction is very important
in terms of stars cop2 infectivity
because this allows
entry of the virus into the host cell
so you can imagine the spike protein
became an important target for
biological clinical and structural
investigations
so that's what part one of my talk will
be focused on is how we were able to
generate large quantities of the spike
protein and looking mostly antibody
responses of other biological
applications as well
and so we'll start with the most obvious
need for the sarcoptes spike
protein which is that
we needed to test sarcopte ii positive
serum
so sterological testing was
important in the beginning for
identification of potential donors of
convalescent plasma
additionally we needed this by protein
ectodomain to identify therapeutic
monoclonal antibodies so how we did that
was we identified single b-cell clones
from convalescent base patients
in addition we also tried to
use the confluence and plasma
to then add into
patients that were
at risk of having a very severe response
to sars cough 2
to potentially
you know get them to not die
biologically uh the spike protein is
very important because it allowed us to
study the mechanisms by which b cells
could respond to startup 2
and what antibodies were being response
were being generated through the
response
we also were interested in t cell
responses but that'll be more on the
second part of my talk
and finally we were also interested in
structural studies so we are a
biochemistry lab that focuses on
immunological targets
so one of our main interests was to do
structural biology and structural
studies on the spike protein
and it became very obvious why it was so
important we needed to know how a spike
protein binds to its receptor of
interest if we can actually find
antibodies that could inhibit
spike binding to its h2 receptor through
antibodies targeting the receptor
binding domain and all this was
really done by a lot of structural
studies
uh
and so that's what made it so important
and most of this work is already
published especially for part one so if
there's anything that
people would like to read in more detail
then please see our publication here
now i'll get started with the outline
so first we're going to be talking about
the protein production and functional
validation
and we were looking at different spike
ectodomain constructs
we decided to look at a few that were
widely used
especially by scientists in our area for
spike protein production
the first we termed op spike 1
which was obtained from the mcclellan
lab
and there are a few key features of this
spike
construct namely the spike actually
domain
which was
boned from amino acid 1 to amino acid
1208
the beginning part of the spike active
domain is termed an s1 region
and the ending part of the ectodomain is
termed s2
and i want to direct you to a few
interesting parts
namely the receptor binding domain
region which is an s1
an additional interesting region is the
s1 s2 cleavage site
which uh for the purposes of our studies
and for the purposes of a lot of those
structural studies
scientists didn't want them to be
cleaved
so
the rrar region
between that was recognized as a
polybasic serine
uh
region
is actually mutated to gsas to avoid
cleavage by s1 s2 proteases
additionally at the very end after the
spike acto domain there's a t4 fiber
chain trimerization motif
and that was utilized to
actually get the spike monomers to
trimmerize in solution
additionally this specific ops bike one
has a protease site which gets rid of
the 8x hiss and the twin strut
tags for ops by 2 which we obtained from
the kramer lab
it is actually very similar to the off
spike 1 protein
except for a few differences namely the
length of the spike ectodomain
goes from 1 to 1 213 amino acids
the mutation to mutagenize the polybasic
furin site
is actually truncated to an a
and
the thrombin cleavage site uh actually
gets rid of the t45 return trimerization
motif and there's a 6x his tag at the
end
but otherwise they're pretty similar
so we decided to use both of these and
purify the proteins using nickel sanity
chromatography and size exclusion
chromatography which we will not be
showing that type of data today
and
because the spiked protein is highly
glycosylated
we didn't want to use prokaryotic
systems we wanted to use eukaryotic
systems to allow for those
post-translational modifications to be
included so we use two systems to
produce the spike protein on the left is
the xp293
transfection kit and on the right is the
xv20 transaction kit which we used for
both of these constructs
so
what happened when we tried to purify
and express
the op spike 1 and up spike 2 using xp
cho and xb 293 systems
on the left is a gel
the nastiest page doll
lane 1 and lane 2 is odd spike one
protein lane three and lane four is
office by two protein
lane one is the opposite one protein
produced next to each hoe and lane two
is the ox spike one produced protein in
xb293
and one of the things that we noticed is
that there is a slight difference in
migration
on the sds page
and this was reproducibly true every
single time we
produced the proteins
and one of the hypothesis was that
there's a difference in
the glycosylation
in
xb293 versus x-metro
so we actually did look at the types of
glycosylation addicts that were present
in xb293 and xv cho produced off spike 1
and we found that there were notable
differences in the types of addicts
present but we will not be discussing
these theta today due to time
constraints
but we found that it was very important
that the spike protein can be
glycosylated and hyperglycosylated
and there are a few studies
showing that it can actually possibly
even affect antibody binding because the
glyco the glycan addicts
are very big and can mask
binding sites of antibodies so
glycosylation of spike is a very
important topic we just do not have time
to go over it today
what we were interested in is also
the expression yields out of these two
systems comparing op spike one versus
ops by two
and what we saw was that overall
obspike one expressed better compared to
op spike two
so we see the first two bars are off
spike 1 produced in xb 293
and ops by 2 produced in xc283 in red
and it was much greater yield for ops
bike 1 producing xb293 versus off spike
two
and the last two bars the green and the
purple bars are up spike one and two
produced next we chose
what we can see is that the green bar
the ops type one protein produced next
to cho produce the highest yield
out of all the different variations
leading us to almost 30 milligrams per
liter
of protein
and this was very important to us
because we knew we had to make a lot of
protein out of the spike protein so
we're trying to figure out what was our
best
cost-effective way to make a lot of
protein uh using less liters of cell
culture so we ended up making 170
milligrams
of oxide 1 protein
generated from these expeditio
cells
and this was compared to the reported
yields of about half a milligram per
liter and had 23 freestyle cells at the
time
so one of the things that i'd like to
point out is that there's differences in
expression systems
and they do have an effect on the
protein glycosylation stability and
yield
and finally of course you make a protein
if there's anything i want to leave you
with is that you have to test the
functionality of the protein you make
so we did this
we expressed human ace2 with the cb
terminal gfp tag in hec283f cells
we then added in our trimeric spike that
has an 8x his tag
and we could detect binding of the spike
protein to these cells
using an anti-his secondary antibody
that has a pe conjugation
and we did this by flow cytometry
so on the y-axis we have the geometric
mean of the pe signal from the antibody
and on the x-axis we have increasing
concentrations
of the trinomial spike protein the black
line represents binding to the human
ace2 expressing cells
whereas the pink
is the mouse 2 expressing cells at the
highest testing concentration
which shows that there's no binding as
expected to mouse ace two but there is
binding to human ace2 indicating that we
purified a functional
non-aggregate spike protein
and so then we proceeded to do some
structural characterization
so we decided to do cryogenic electron
microscopy
uh and single particle reconstruction to
assess the tertiary and quaternary
assessments
of the s protein
and we actually do this for both xb293
and xp show express opt spike one
but here i'm just showing the off spike
one produced in xb2
and this was done with uh dr jeffrey
bonanno from the alma lab and the new
york structural biology center
and there was at the time a lot of
reported stars cop2s by crayon
structures displaying the trimeric spike
existing in both a closed conformation
so all the receptor binding domains
pointing downward
or there was also a lot of heterogeneity
which were the spike monomers were also
in the open conformation so you had a
lot of structures that had one spike
monomer
with the receptor binding doing pointing
upwards
we're here just showing
the one spike structure we solved
which is the symmetrical triangle so all
the spike
monomers have the receptor binding
domain pointing downward this was the
easiest structure
to solve
so we did this at a 3.22 angstrom
resolution and
we inserted our structure as a pb file
6x6p
on the left we have the side view of the
spike primer with each monomer colored
in a different color so black gray
and then the purple ribbon
on the bottom is you're looking at the
viral membrane
and
the very top part is where the s1 is so
where the receptor binding domain and
the n-terminal domain are
closer to the viral membrane you have
closer to the s2 region of the x-spike
acto domain
and if we look at the top view so we're
looking at the very top of the spike
timer
we see that again
the whole primer is symmetrical
and each monomer is colored in a
different color
but we didn't just want to look at the
by trimer and do a crime structure on it
we also wanted to look at
how this compares to all the solid
structures at the time
so we did an analysis of all the
criminal structures solved at the time
and this was just looking at all the
spike trimers that were symmetrical
meaning all the receptor binding domains
were pointing downward
and so there was 20 cryoam structures
that we aligned
to pdb file 6v xx
and what we noticed is on the left when
we're looking at the side view
they all agreed pretty well with one
another which was
pretty fascinating that 20
different labs could generate all of
these criom structures and they could
all agree with each other
the s2 region seems to be less variable
while the s1 region
closer to the top seems to be slightly
more variable
and if we look at the top view we really
see the variability
the receptor binding domains in the
center and the n-terminal domains
on the outside of the top view where you
can see that there's generally more
variability compared to s2 region
but they seem to agree with one another
overall
when we looked at all the 20 kryolium
structures we actually saw something
pretty fascinating which is if you look
at all these cryovm structures you see
that there's two distinct conformations
in a particular region and that's in the
region of amino acid 614
to 642.
so this is conformation one on the left
where we're really highlighting the
region of interest 614 to 642 in magenta
and you'll notice that there's red stars
this indicates where
there's missing amino acids and that
could be due hypothetically to
uh variability or disorder in those
regions so they couldn't map the region
so they're missing amino acids 621 to
640 and this con in this case
but looking at nine structures the
region of interest and magenta aligns
pretty well
um and it aligns to the specific region
of conformation one
but the second set of structures that we
looked at
um and there were seven of the criom
structures that fit conformation two
and you'll notice that the magenta
region is now pointing in a different
uh area
and it has a different conformation
and these set of structures were missing
amino acids
631
except for one of the structures which
actually did model the whole entire
region
another thing that's very interesting
when we looked at confirmation ii
we found that the region highlighted in
blue
right under the magenta region
uh which constitutes amino acids 828 to
854 was not present in conformation 1
and in confirmation 2 this region it
seems to be pretty ordered
so this is very exciting because it
suggests that
the confirmation that these structures
take
really affects this other separate
segment
so what we found is that
there were two confirmations distinct
confirmations our model actually seemed
to display confirmation one
which was very exciting
um but spike seems to exhibit at least
two different conformational states for
the segment containing amino acids 614
to 642
and this seems to affect
the stability or the the ordering of
amino acids 828 to 854
and this was pretty interesting to us
and the biological implications
of these conformational states has yet
to be
studied
and so lastly i want to go through
biological applications so there are a
few that i'm very interested in
our lab has developed a multi-antigen
protein array which i'll discuss first
dr lev's uh in our lab has uh developed
this sarcopte ii multi-antigen protein
array where we take sars cuffs to purify
antigens and we cross link them to amino
cell in glass slides
we then add in human serum to the slides
and if the human serum contains an
antibody that can bind to the antigen
for example here in this picture we have
spike protein
then we can detect that bound antibody
using an antihuman igg antibody and we
can do this not just for igg antibodies
but for iga and igm
isotype antibodies
so the stars costume multi-angiogram
protein array looks something like this
on the right we have a stars cop2
negative serum where we really only see
two signals
the human igg control at the very top
and the human iga control at the very
bottom uh
boxed in green
we also have two sars class 2 serums
here just as an example
where we see that we get much more
signal
where we see full length spike boxed in
yellow
s2 region s1 region boxed in blue the
receptor binding domain
nucleocapsid which is boxed in white at
the very bottom
and the
mu mutant version of spike which is
d614g
which is boxed above nucleic acid that
also seems to have a very bright signal
for these two serums so we have a lot of
options with this type of protein array
and this type of platform to screen for
different antigens different
spike variants
and look at different types of antibody
responses
and i'm just going to show a quick
overview of what this would look like
so here we're just looking at two
positive serums serum 12 in serum 15
which restarts cost 2 positive
and a sarcopte ii negative serum which
is in green
and we're looking at igg spike
antibodies
spiked iga antibodies and spike m
antibodies and what you see is that
overall
serum 15 has a higher antibody response
compared to serum 12.
and on the x-axis is where we're looking
at
the log dilution of the of the serum so
the more antibody you have obviously the
more response signal you'll get
on the bottom we're looking at the
receptor binding domain binding
so receptor binding domain igg
antibodies iga and igm and of course
serum 15 has a higher antibody response
for everything than serum 12.
and what she's really trying to do
is see
how these
levels of antibody responses
correlate with overall
clinical outcome for these patients
so as you can tell this platform is very
exciting because it allows us to
characterize the antibody responses to
source costs ii
but also we have a platform that allows
us to characterize antibody responses to
any type of viral infection
so next i wanted to talk about another
platform that's uh in our lab that's
very exciting
which is a high throughput screen of a
human secret dome and we wanted to look
at novel spike binding partners
so what we did is we took
a library expressing
several types of c-terminal
gfp fusions but here in my cartoon i'm
just showing ace2
human ace 2 has a positive control
where humanist 2 expressing cells will
bind to the trimeric spike at 500
nanomolar concentration and we can
detect this binding using an anti-his
secondary antibody that's pe conjugated
and we can detect this by flow cytometry
so looking at our gsp expression library
we were able to do
a high throughput um small scale hectic
iii freestyle transfections
of our library members
wait 48 hours
and then add in recombinant spike 1
to the transfected cells
we then added in our pe conjugated
antihis
and we performed high throughput flow
cytometry to determine whether or not
any cells would bind to our trimeric
spike
and as you can imagine we did this with
spike protein purified by protein but we
could have also done this with
cells expressing spike
or any other target of interest
so when we did this we were first
looking at a few
main targets of interest
human ace2 which is a positive control
with the geometric mean on the y axis
mouse phase 2 which does not uh have
signal indicating there's no binding
as our negative control
and there were two
receptors present here that were of
interest to us at the time
cd147 which is was actually a proposed
binding partner for spike at one point
and has now been um
shown it is not by several lab members
in several different labs including
ourselves
uh so we did indeed not find binding of
cd147 to spike
we also didn't find binding a spike to
cd26
which is a receptor for mers coronavirus
and we did not find binding for that as
well
looking at our high throughput screen
results we screened 20 percent of a
human secret home to look for novels
fight binding partners and we found
nothing
so in green we have binding of spike to
human ace2 expressing cells which was
always our positive control to ensure
that our spike protein was working
properly
and in purple we have fc receptor
expressing cells
which
um are able to bind to the antibody we
add to detect binding so these were also
false positives
a library consists of immunoglobulin
super family members tnf receptor super
family members integrin family members
gpcrs and chemokine receptors just to
mention a few
and we did not detect binding of spike
to any of the receptors that at the time
the literature was saying spike could
find two so integrins c 147
cyglic 9 and cyglic 10 c chem 1 and
secant 5 were all at one point
um speculated or thought to have bind to
spike and we showed that that was not
the case
but this platform is very interesting
because it allows us to find binary
partners
in a high throughput fashion not just
for stars club 2 spike but for any type
of other
ligand or protein of interest
and so i'll quickly summarize part one
we have an optimized by protein
production protocol
where we actually express large amounts
of spike protein in expeditio cells
and we showed their spike protein
using our purification scheme is a good
quality and is functional
and spiked protein produced in expo cho
cells is differentially glycosylated
compared to the published analysis of
spike protein produced in hectic three
freestyle cells which
we
just didn't have time to show today
unfortunately but we also see that spike
protein can be utilized for several
downstream applications
so we screen and we're currently
screaming for
antibody responses to patients that have
been exposed to sarcopte we're looking
at igg igm
and iga antibody responses to several
stars called two antigens including
spooling spike
screening for spike interactions with
new with all the receptors in the human
secret home has thus far yielded no new
interactions but i'm still a big fan of
this platform so i wanted to talk about
it
and the spike protein has been utilized
by a lot of our collaborators for
clinically relevant experiments looking
at convalescent plasma
b-cell sorting
and so i just did not have time to go
over all of this data today
but spike protein does remain
relevant for these types of
analyses the second part of my talk
which is a smaller portion
is looking at whether or not we can
modulate stars cop2 cd8 positive t cell
responses
and so
when you have a sarcop2 infection
there are different arms of the immune
system that play an essential role you
have the immune system
but you also have the adaptive immune
system which also plays a significant
role
and a lot of scientists have focused on
the b cell arm where you have plasma
cells that secrete antibodies that can
neutralize sars cough too
and prevent entry of source cough two
into host cells
and while that is very important
we in our lab are very interested in
looking at the t cells and specifically
the cytotoxic t lymphocytes and these
are important for finding
virally infected cells and killing them
so any cell that would be infected with
sarcopte ii
would have to interact with the
cytotoxic t lymphocyte and the cytotoxic
t lymphocyte should recognize and kill
these spirally infected cells
so one of the interesting things that we
found uh there are a few
uh publications out there suggesting
that unexposed individuals have cd4
positive and cda positive t cells
that can actually respond to sars cop2
and the hypothesis being that these
people have been exposed to common cold
coronaviruses
that have a high degree of conservation
in some parts of
you know
spike or some parts of viral proteins
and these viral proteins were presented
to cd4 and cd positive t cells and these
t cells can now respond to sars cop2
because of that
an additional hypothesis
that several scientists have including
our lab is that those individuals might
have a milder response to sars cop2
because of previous exposure
to common cold coronaviruses
so our goal is whether or not we can
actually activate those stars cost two
cd8 positive t cells specifically
because cd8 positive t cells can find
and kill virally infected cells
and we want to see if we can activate
these cd8 positive t cells in unexposed
as well as exposed individuals
to
prime the immune system before stars
cough to exposure
so what would it look like to get
activation of a cd8 positive t cell we
have a schematic on the right where
we're looking at cd8 positive t cell on
the right
on the top
expressing a t cell receptor
now
on the bottom we have an antigen
presenting cell which is going to do
exactly what the name says which is
present antigen so let's say that cell
itself the antigen presenting cell um
took in virus
and especially starts cough two virus
and chopped up the proteins and now is
presenting a saris club 2-peptide onto
its mhc class 1.
if the t cell expresses a t cell
receptor that can bind to this mhc
peptide combination
then it can start to become activated
but it needs an additional
co-stimulation or a secondary signal in
order to become really activated so here
i'm just showing an example where we get
il2 co-stimulation
but
co-stimulation can occur in different
ways
um il-2 can activate t cells
cd28 can activate t cells there's
different ways that we can activate t
cells this is just one example
what we like to do in our lab is we
developed a novel class of
immunomodulatory proteins and they're
termed syntax
they're artificial immunological synapse
for t-cell activation
and this is just a protein reagent that
we're using to mimic the antigen
presenting cell
so what we have is the mhc
class 1 in pink
with the peptide in orange
and we also have it linked to something
that can modulate t-cell activation so
il-2 or something that can activate
td-28
for example
but what happens here is that the
c8-positive t-cell has a t-cell receptor
that can interact with the mhc and
peptide so this will activate the t cell
receptors and giving the t cell
signal 1 to be activated
you can also get a signal 2 or
co-stimulatory signal to further
activate that t cell by giving it il2
and using these syntax biomolecules
we can activate t cells
in an antigen specific fashion
because now we're only activating the t
cells that have a very specific t cell
receptor
and so what that t cell would do when
it's activated
is shown on the left so that t cell that
expresses that very specific t cell
receptor
is now able to detect
when a infected cell has been infected
with sars cough ii
because the sars cough two infected cell
will process sarcophagi antigens present
the peptides onto mhc class 1
and if the cd8 positive t cell expresses
a t cell receptor
that is capable of binding this complex
then it will perform an immune attack
and kill the infected cell that's
exactly what we want
and
really something that we want to do
is not just activate one specific cd8
positive t cell with one specific t cell
receptor clone we just want to make an
array
of different stars cos2 epitope syntax
to target several different types of cd8
positive t cells that can all respond to
stars cough ii
peptides
so the goal is to really do this to
activate c8 positive t cells
and have them be activated towards stars
called two infected cells now do these
syntax biomolecules work
we have evidence to show that they do
so looking at
an hiv-infected donor
we were able to take out
hiv pbmcs or peripheral blood
mononuclear cells these peripheral blood
mononuclear cells contain
several types of cells including cd8
positive t cells
but all of these cells get injected into
a non-skid gamma mouse
this non-skip skid gamma mouse
actually is very immunodeficient and
lacks mature t cells b cells and natural
killer cells
so this allows us to engraft primary
human cells into this mouse model
we actually take uh the mouse plane
after seven days and do flow cytometry
analysis
and we do this for either untreated
or mice that were treated with
a syntactic biomolecule and this syntax
biomolecule
is targeting the hiv
specific cd8 positive t cells
now
this is the data so on the left we have
um
staining of an untreated
mouse splenocytes where we're looking at
the cd8 marker on the bottom axis on the
x-axis
and the sl9 tetramer on the y-axis so
this sl9 tetramer is a protein reagent
that can bind specifically to the hiv
peptide
to the t cell receptor expressed on t
cells sorry
that can respond to the hiv peptide
termed sl9
so we see that we have about 0.35
of the total
cells
are specific for this hiv peptide so
only 0.35 of the t cells of this hiv
infected individual
can respond to
hiv infected cells
in the middle what we have is actually
the same type of staining experiment but
this was after treating with our hiv
syntax
so now the goal is
can we activate and proliferate
these t cells
in the mouse and the answer was yes
comparing untreated to the sl9 anti-cd28
where we have the sl9 hiv peptide loaded
on mhc which will specifically bind to
and activate hiv specific t cell
receptors
and we have anti cd28 which can activate
cd28 molecules on t cells to further
stimulate t cell activation
what we see is we get
12.1 percent of the population is now
that specific
t cell
that can respond to hiv infected cells
we've expanded that population
and now we're looking at a negative
control which has the incorrect peptide
it has a cmv peptide loaded onto mhc
class 1. we see that the hiv
specific t cells
do not have the t cell receptors to
respond to this attack so we should get
no expansion
and indeed if we look above at the
staining we do not see that that's the
case
so if we look at the quantification
the hiv specific anti-cd28 syntactic in
the middle
activates cd8 positive t cells in an
antigen specific fashion
so we got expansion of these t cells in
an in vivo format
and actually we've shown that these t
cells are active towards
hiv infected cells and for lack of time
we will not be going over that today
so it's very exciting we've shown that
syntactic biomolecules can activate
viral specific cd8 t cells
so we have privacy to believe that we
can use this platform for stars cough ii
as well
and so the current work in the lab
is to generate a variety of these herbs
cop2 syntax so on the left is an sds
page drill of one
peptide in the syntax platform in a
small scale
initial test
and we saw that we get protein which is
very exciting but of course we want to
take advantage of
all of the resources we have through the
mtdf to screen for greater than 52
different source cop2 epitopes in the
syntax platform and using different
types of cell types ex cho and xp293
to
optimize expression of the syntax
and with that i'd like to end uh part
two
where we're really doing uh this is
really work in progress we're looking at
optimizing the expression
and purification of these syntactic
biomolecules
in several different cell types xp cho
xb293 and hec293
and we're really going to start looking
at trying to expand the starscoff to
specific cda positive t cells and see if
we can activate them towards starzkov2
starscoff2 infected cells
in either exposed or unexposed
individuals to starscop2
and with that i'd like to thank all of
our collaborators there's a long list of
collaborators here
um i'd like to thank albert einstein
college of medicine montefiore cubar
biopharma who's doing the syntactic work
and thermo fisher scientific for this
wonderful opportunity and with that i'd
like to
take any questions
thank you natalia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started
our first question
is
how effective is the syntax at
activating antigen-specific t cells
okay
hi
yeah excellent question
so
the syntax themselves are pretty
effective at at least the ones that we
test we've tested at activating um
t-cells
so here i'm just showing uh a slide
where we're looking at
markers of activation so the t cells
would be
either secreting tnf alpha and
interferon gamma
and to compare
in the
immunological field a lot of people use
an anti-cd3
anti-c28 um
antibody
for general activation of t cells so
that's what we're comparing it to and if
we're looking at our antigen specific
activation where we're only activating
the t cells
that
can respond to the sl9 hiv peptide
with an additional cd28
activation
attached to the syntax we see that we
can activate those t cells pretty well
and we have differences in activation
mods so like activation uh with
secondary molecules so cd28
or 401 bbl
um so yeah they're very effective if we
look down below the tnif alpha
interfering gamma we also see perforin
and cd107 a markers so those are also
pretty
um those t-cells are staining pretty
well after syntactic treatment
so yeah they're pretty pretty nice and
effective
thank you natalia our next question
can you use the high throughput secret
home screen for the identification of
novel interactions in disease contacts
for example screen for binding partners
to tumor cells
um yes so if we
look at our slide that
was shown previously
we were using purified
spike protein
and uh but this isn't to say that we
can't use other types of
ways to present ligands or receptors of
interest so we have done this type of
screen with cells expressing
ligands and then we screen against the
library of cells
and much like that you can also take a
cancer cell line of interest and see
what you can find for binding using this
uh
high throughput platform as well
[Music]
all right thank you again natalia
our next question
can you utilize the sars kobe 2
multi-antigen protein array to screen
for differences in antibody responses to
sars kobe 2 spike variants for example
can we measure if there is a notable
difference in antibody responses to the
delta variant
yes so uh
going back to this slide
um we were able to
use our sars clock 2 antigen
multi-protein array to look at different
spike variants as well
some of the notable ones that we have
used
um
is the n501y mutation the d641
d614g mutation and then the delta
variations as well as others
and that's work that's currently done in
our lab and we'll be
trying to get it published soon yeah
that's a great question
all right well thank you natalia that's
all we have time for today do you have
any final comments for our audience
um
yeah
i guess if anyone's interested in
uh in our lab reach out to
to us
my my lab is looking for technicians for
the mtdf and for
all postdocs uh who are interested in
this kind of work specifically the
syntax
uh platform
and yeah any other questions that we're
pressing feel free to contact me since
we didn't get to all the questions today
thank you again natalia for your time
today and for your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor gibco by thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye